c'est un reportage qui devrait à nouveau
faire grand bruit le 14 novembre
prochain sera diffusé en prime sur ces
huit la suite du documentaire sur la
sphère christian quesada qui avait
défrayé la chronique il ya plusieurs
mois avec au programme de nouvelles
révélations exclusives pour rappel
christian cazade à s'est fait connaître
du grand public en 2016 en participant
aux 12 coups de midi sur tf1 il restera
le champion de l'émission au fil de 193
participation faisant de lui le
recordman des 12 coups de midi au total
il empochera 800000 euros de gains c'est
en mars 2010neuf que la face sombre de
l'homme est dévoilée lorsqu'il est mis
en examen et placé en détention
provisoire pour corruption de mineurs et
possession de milliers d'imagés à
caractère pédopornographique
si le premier volet de ce documentaire
avait révélé en exclusivité le
témoignage de nombreuses victimes
présumées de quesada christian a proféré
des menaces de mort avant de rencontrer
une commence à me faire des câlins et
bisous sur la bouche et du couffin shape
à caen à réagir ce deuxième reportage
contient lui aussi son lot de
révélations cette fois ci de nouvelles
victimes supposées ont décidé elle aussi
de témoigner et des proches raconteront
également son rapport parfois malsain à
l'argent si ses différentes
participations à des jeux télé l'ont
presque rendu millionnaire christian
quesada été pour le moins proche de ses
soupirs encore il aurait même refusé de
rembourser ses dettes alors qu'il en
avait largement les moyens faudrait
quand même que tu penses à rembourser
je tends prêter de l'argent la planche
au derrière de nouvelles révélations à
découvrir le 14 novembre prochain sur
ces 8 alors les nouvelles révélations
sur cristaux quesada stop ou encore
alors donc on a le documentaire est en
cours de montage tout n'est pas terminé
vous voulez vous montrer ses nombreux
ces nouveaux témoignages
on a par exemple un témoignage exclusif
et journaliste pour trouver à une
ancienne amie manipulé par question qui
sanaa lorsqu'il avait besoin d'argent
alors tous les moyens étaient bons pour
lui soutirer quelques euros regardez ça
noël et nous n'avons pas été les seuls
nous avons reçu un message de christian
des angles il ne pourrait pas été
correctement noël avec ses enfants parce
que font alors bien mon compagnon lui
adresser un chèque il y avait
apparemment peut faire la fête parce que
enfin chez pour 200 euros à ce moment là
il n'avait pas ses enfants alors on peut
penser qu'il y en ai pas vu la couleur
je pense que l'argent qu'il est arrivé à
gratter de 6 de la cedh et pour son
usage personnel faut certainement les
jeux de grattage et cigarettes
il utilisait ses enfants parce que on
attendrait forcément en période de noël
parler d'enfants de l'ormeau ça vous
fait rire vraiment une question alors
trois extraits et vous allez nous dire
après stop ou encore garde j'ai un autre
reste à démontrer
c'est suite aux révélations sur question
qui s'adonnent à un ami d'enfance qui
raconte que christian a toujours eu un
comportement assez étrange et se
souvient notamment d'une scène étonnante
alors c'est un truc de ouf
regardez ce témoignage il dit une scène
étonnante où il se masturbait sur son
balcon à anthony regarder ses premiers
déboires avec la justice en raison de
ses déviances sexuelles
quesada s'est bien gardé de les évoquer
dans son autobiographie comme nous le
rappelle son ami d'enfance
alors savait que ça allait pas les tenir
jusqu'au bout
je voudrais que le camp d'en face fasse
preuve de la même honnêteté
intellectuelle que nous quand on tombe
sur une personnalité monstrueux on a
envie d'en savoir plus voilà il ya une
partie de nous qui est dégoûté il ya une
partie de nous qui l'être non mais qui
va être dissous être honnête il faut le
reconnaître on est attiré par les
personnalités monstre en savoir plus
voir suite je le dis franchement c'est
sûr voilà alors un non sérieusement je
mérite ce qui est produit ce
documentaire il méritait voilà bah c'est
vous non mais vous pouvez dire stop
c'est ce que je vous dis il ya plus de
temps de jeu suscite au québec on a
beaucoup beaucoup parlé mais on apprend
de trois choses si ce n'est que l'on
savait des acteurs personnage un petit
peu compliqué et que visiblement ça fait
c'est pas une nouveauté qui soit un
personnage dangereux pour les pour les
autres donc effectivement on n'apprend
pas grand chose selon moi voilà bien une
série de minutes mais avec je vous ai
fait une émission horrible mais le
mauvais éviter pour dire une de tes
meilleurs allaient remonter l'âge mais
déjà être sérieux deux minutes j'ai
marché
d'abord merci non
[Applaudissements]
alors oui maintenant est ce que je veux
dire d'un bon petit 1 c'est quand même
une affaire qui est très important car
j'ai donné sa requête très grave
oui c'est une affaire qui n'a pas encore
été jugés et que quelque part pardon
c'est vous qui la produisent et vous
juger sur deux prime puisque de vous
forcément quand on voit ces prime on a
un avis sur une personne finalement
qu'on ne connaît pas encore très bien
c'est la justice qui vais décider et
uniquement la justice petit 2 et là où
je n'en avais un petit peu plus cyril
c'est que là franchement on va faire de
l'audience avait quelque chose chez non
mais écoutez franchement non je rigole
pas là on va faire de l'audience avait
quelque chose qui effectivement est
grave avait quelque chose qui est pardon
c'est du lycée d'une bad buzz je trouve
que ça ne nous ressemble pas j'ai envie
qu'on soit avec des chimistes ou encore
une fois de quoi semer le ton je déteste
quand la télé devient judiciaire on est
c'est fini l'époque de pradelles quand
il sera jugé
on pourra faire tuer documentaire du
monde s'étonne est en prison vous dire
que j'en sais rien non mais c'est vous
dire comment ça se passe sinon moi je
suis producteur
oui la chaîne me passe une commande me
dit voilà on aimerait faire un deuxième
doc / quesada parce qu'ils prennent
cette affaire très au sérieux
il aura envie de le faire modifier est
ce que tu peux le faire et je n'y avais
bien appel de la salle d'audience pardon
je mal de la salle vous voulez pas trop
vieille à des nouvelles infos c'est
notre affaire qui voit là kik intéresse
tout moun lindgren celle affaire très
grave
isabelle voilà après moi je vous dis
vous dj stoxx comprend sérieuses à un
juge d'instruction qui mènent j'aimerais
pas non et je respecte le stock
maintenant on revient sur la faire avec
des nouveaux éléments avec des nouvelles
des nouveaux témoignages
voilà c'est au leader moi je n'aime pas
qu'on préjugés à leur pardonne moi moi
je l'aimé je suivais quand il était
candidat ça m'intéressait avant ça m'a
intéressé pendant je me suis senti trahi
comme tout le monde j'ai suivi de la
faire et maintenant ce qui va se passer
ensuite m'intéresse aussi n'avait pas
dire qu'on va crapoter pendant tout un
document tu sais pas du tout le contenu
tu regardais même pas les images tout à
l'heure mais ça n'a rien à voir c'est
parce que chanter alors bien qu est l
affaire est très grave yens justice
laisser d'abord nagé on cesse comprendre
bien des jeux et des reculs sion qui
sont là pour instruire une affaire
ouais c'est pas une boîte de prod
wilshere qui m'intéresse c'est simon va
parler de ton juste vous parlez du
premier documentaire
oui c'est vrai qu'elle est très bien
marché et parmi les témoignages avait
celui de melissa l'une des victimes
présumées de christian quesada elle
raconte comment christian aurait dérapé
alors qu'elle l'accompagnait à paris
pour un tournage vous rappelez de
mélissa et voilà on va revenir aussi sur
tout ça on va on a dû
vous et les mots dans la sphère c'est
pour ça qu'il ya un deuxième
documentaire regardé c'était lors du
premier malgré les réticences de la
jeune fille quesada décide quand même de
l'emmener à l'hôtel on va dans la
chambre est ici y va sur le lit et une
faible bien côté nord du coup je mens
moi je vais à côté de lui dans le lit et
on est face à face dans l'est on est
couché face à face et là il ne commence
à me faire des câlins et des bisous sur
la bouche et du coup fin je savais pas
comment réagir enfin au bout de
10 bisous je ne dirai je met ma main
devant la bouche mais non il a enlevé la
main et continuer et du coup fin je me
retournais pour j'étais en pleurs j'ai
essayé d'appeler ma mère plusieurs fois
une fête a pas de quoi pleurer tu à
réaliser ton rêve tu vas avoir serré les
camille combal
alors oui je vais rebondir sur ce les
amériques a dit oh mon ami matthieu
delormeau désole t peut-être
nostalgiques de l'union soviétique où tu
aimerais bien vite en corée du nord mais
en france on compte pas que sur le
pouvoir ne désinformation est aussi
j'analyse quoi rôle très important
d'investigations ils font très souvent
progresser les affaires parlementaires
dont pardon et mais il y avait une
tendance apportant et part donc avec
tout le respect que j'ai pour elle mena
les journées certaines joueuses à la
luna donc la boîte h2o il ya des
journalistes d'investigation a suffi de
deux ans d'enquêté
tu pense qu'il ya un an ou deux ans dans
ce qu'elle peut a ouvert la première
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui h dessous vous
savez combien de noms de gens disent
quelque chose au milieu mais le nombre
de gens travaillent et une bêtise
reconnaître que je voulais une seconde
les articles qui paraissent dans la
presse n'est pas au bout de deux ans
d'investigations mes affaires sont
couvertes au jour le jour par la presse
pourquoi elle ne le seraient pas dans un
documentaire est bien sûr de la qualité
en s'assurant qu'aucun son éditorial
voilà que de parler ou pas encore de
quesada à la télévision il est depuis
huit mois en détention provisoire à la
prison de bourg en bresse
le 25 mars dernier les gendarmes l'ont
interpellé à son domicile voilà donc ces
ordinateurs ont été saisis et son nouvel
avocat donné une interview au journal le
progrès le 17 mai dernier il disait il à
thenay il admet être attiré par les
adolescentes mais pas par les enfants
concernant les photos sur son ordinateur
ce sont des fantasmes sans aucune
volonté de passage à l'acte les
accusations sont disproportionnées cssa
da ce n'est pas du trou alors voilà vous
le savez voilà on a on a bouclé ce
nouveau documentaire avec beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de nouveaux
témoignages
il a fonctionné jeudi prochain sa fille
marie la semaine reste donc c'est pour
ça
le début on nous impose et elle s'est
imposée à nous on attend j'ai envie de
béroul la pelote et d'avoir la fin de
l'histoire
toi tu étais la famille par cheney
justice qui décidera tout conte fait pas
de pouls qu'on fait pas après le gentil
rice amitié pour qu'on fait pas à brême
tandis qu'il se passe quelque chose
gilles est ce qu'on appelle en détention
provisoire c'est à dire que oui on sait
que ce monsieur a fait des choses sales
mais on ne sait pas encore de quoi il va
être condamné comment il va être
condamné
mais encore une fois je trouve que
condamnation à l'accusation ne fait pas
condamnation c'est pas nous sépare nous
de faire des promenades et chopin alors
les chants d'adieu à décharge un procès
ils ont enquêté
on apprend les choses sur le personnel
pour le coup tu dis des grosses bêtises
c'est pas le procès dans l'émission ah
oui on équipe à dix
en fait on en saura un peu plus sur qui
existe dans ce cas là vous arrêter à
l'instigation géraldine maillet bat
vincent et moi je trouve que en fait
effectivement il est il est mis en
examen pour détention et diffusion
d'imagés pédopornographiques donc ça
c'est très grave pour corruption de
mineurs ça c'est très grave sur moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on sorte un peu sur la
vague parce qu'elle est elle éduque
rassis parce que ça marche
bon après je vois là je suis un petit
peu gêné parce que je pense un peu comme
mathieu que c'est c'est du ressort de la
justice et de l'instruction comme on
devrait les serge et vos droits et vous
n'avez le droit de dire géraldine je
comprends tout à fait votre position
j'ai pris un bon mois juste en mon nom
moi je comprends ce qu'a dit eric tout à
l'heure les gens ont besoin peut-être
d'entendre de savoir l'histoire comme a
dit jean-michel ils veulent aller au
bout de l'histoire moi pourquoi j'ai dit
stop
parce que ça y'est j'annonce agents nas
entendu il m'a énormément déçu m'a
énormément fait de peine j'ai voilà son
histoire aléas des allées sordide il est
en prison
attendons qu'ils soient jugés quand il
sera jugé qu on aura tous les éléments
on pourra dire ce qu'on voudra c'est
moins que ce que mon point de vue pas
lésé des gens ils pensent qu'ils autant
quand les jeunes filles elles viennent
pour pour s'exprimer et qu'il a fait
quelque chose de mal
ça c'est très bien et parce que ça
faisait six styles à paroles elle peut
se dédaigné ou des loups et comme dit
nicole quand tu dis bien au fond des
rivières et on a compris ça d'accord
mais là moi c'est avec des points de vue
comme le tien patrick dils est toujours
prisés sont quatre existants du
journaliste pour un rôle mais je sais
que tous les journalistes n'ont pas
drôle c'est le film parce que je suis en
train de dire il dit qu'elle dit rien
sur parlons c'est votre documentaire
mais quelqu'un sur un balcon qui me dit
son avion
mais moi je peux la faire moi la vidéo
sur mon balcon comme ça c'est ces
énoncés
isabelle ça moi j'ai dit c'est ce que tu
dis pardon mais non tu banane est
systématiquement le travail des autres
qui tenait qu'ils ont pas fait leur
honneur le boulot en toute conscience et
oui les questions ne se substituait la
justice il n'est pas qu'on va faire le
travail à la place de la justice
on dit que les journalistes font leur
travail de leur côté certaines machines
chez l'autre j'aime me dire à moi
pourtant très vite que de là où tu dis
une erreur et l'autre fois j'étais
choqué dans cette émission et pourtant
dieu sait si on peut lui parler
librement dans cette émission il ya
justement potere ces métiers il ya eu un
témoignage d'aucun témoignage j'ai
entendu quelqu'un parler je savais pas
qui c'était qu étaient masqués j'ai pas
vu son visage
c'est quelqu'un qui parlait je sais pas
d'où il sortait rahmane on parle à la
télé c'est un témoignage la part dont
moi ça me choque
je trouve que c'est pas loin et écolo
dans les mecs qui vont aux antilles
quand vous voyez des témoignages alors
laissons nous mais la balade par exemple
mais une bourde est très bonne info même
dans le parisien ya souvent des jo sans
il dit
voilà qui vient témoigner les jo il est
très amusant après ce voyage alors
amassé téléspectateurs tiens allez stop
ou encore stop aux bagnes sont d'accord
avec vous ce top a sonné pour 22%
récemment corps